get the [__] off get him out
Avril Lavigne confronts a topless woman
on live TV at the 2023 Juno Awards what
this is happening on Monday the
complicated singer took the stage to
introduce a performance during the
Canadian award show that's when a woman
crashed the stage with a message written
on her back save the green belt a
reference to a controversial development
plan by the Ontario government initially
Avril ignored the protester but that
didn't last long get the [__] off
welcome
a security guard escorted the woman off
the stage and the show's host Marvel
star simu Liu later praised the punk
rocker for handling the topless lady
Like A Champion
[Applause]
oh there's so many things I didn't
expect to happen
in my life later Avril accepted another
trophy The Tick Tock Juno Fan Choice
Award and addressed that chaotic moment
during her speech now nobody tried
anything this time or the You know
despite being honored at the event
avril's new bow Tyga did not attend the
pair sparked romance rumors when they
popped up at the same Paris Fashion Week
events earlier this month and seemingly
confirmed their relationship locking
lips at the moogler by Hunter Schaefer
party a month after the skater boy
singer and her former fiance mod sun
called off their engagement
a source previously told ET that Avril
and Tyga are having a lot of fun
together they connect over music and
fashion and have mutual friends so it's
easy and nice they're cute with each
other and the attraction between them is
strong
as for Avril and Madsen she's an icon so
I'm just lucky to be next to her the two
got engaged in Paris in March 2022. my
girl is a straight princess
she's a straight princess so like you
know it's going to be grandiose 100 Punk
Legends are going to be at this wedding
is what I want to know oh yeah he's
going to be a room full of it man it's
just gonna be a giant Mosh Pit the whole
night has Avril picked out a dress yet
no not yet but they called it quits last
month
[Music]
a source at the time told E.T that
things hadn't been great between them
for a while and after trying to make it
work Avril realized the relationship
wasn't right for her but all's well that
ends well and Avril is clearly one tough
cookie
[Music]
[Applause]